mais c'est même pas pour les plus aisés
c'est un budget pour les super riches
même pas ceux qui créent parce qu' il
peut y avoir des gens qui est des moyens
en france
et moi je suis pour l'initiative privée
je suis pour que ceux qui veulent gagner
puisse gagner de l'argent mais là c'est
pas ça c'est un budget de remerciement
pour campagne électorale 5 milliards à
peu près pour les plus fortunés des
fortunés parce que même des gens qui ont
des biens immobiliers vont continuer à
payer les sf mais en revanche ceux qui
sont de la finance vont être exonérés
donc c'est le sait le budget le plus
provocateur pour les français qui existe
il renvoie l'ascenseur à ceux qui ont
financé sa campagne à cette oligarchie à
cette super classe et il va faire
souffrir les français comme jamais je ne
l'accepté pas
c'est un gigantesque manipulateur
manipulateur sur la sphère alstom qu'on
fait passer pour un dossier européen
alors que c'est une prise de pouvoir de
siemens manipulateur sur la création
d'entreprise
alors que les impôts sur les charges sur
les pme vont augmenter l'année prochaine
je n'accepte pas ces manipulations